foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm nazarez and welcome to an all
new episode of RT Essentials today we
are doing it we are putting our heads on
the chopping block for your judgment not
exactly a New Concept for us here at
Rotten Tomatoes but on this episode
we're going to be running down the
scariest horror movies of all time and
like many things what makes you scream
get the goose pimples or cry in the
fetal position until dawn is super
subjective I mean the classic jump scare
might do it for most While others might
need that deep existentially disturbing
reach into their psyche to just really
mess them up so we tried our best to
keep it spoiler light around here but
since we're talking about movies that
date all the way back to 1960 well I
mean there's only so long the world can
protect you from psycho's big plot twist
or finding out which horror movie
franchise Prometheus was a not so secret
prequel for so consider yourself warned
okay now it is time to sit back relax
and maybe get startled when something
behind you jumps on the couch these are
Rotten Tomatoes the scariest horror
movies of all time okay move
now
spelunking has never been scarier than
Neil Marshall's 2005 underground monster
movie The Descent starring Shauna
McDonald and Natalie Mendoza the story
centers around a cave exploring trip
gone Bottoms Up When the ceiling
collapses trapping a group of women
hundreds of feet below the Earth which
is a terrifying image by itself and
that's before you add in the
Subterranean vampires
[Applause]
The Descent was so scary it spooked its
own creator after writing the film
Marshall who had originally wanted to
shoot on location in the Appalachian
Mountains decided it was too dangerous
to film in an actual cave and opted to
build one instead and boy was it a set
made up of 21 interlocking rooms that
could be shot at various camera angles
to give the impression of endless
caverns and adding to the creep Factor
the actors were actually moving around
in near total darkness with only what
they had on their bodies flashlights
helmet lights and light sticks
as for the monsters themselves they were
based on the vampire from Nosferatu it
took three and a half hours in the
makeup chair to transform a single actor
into a crawler and the cast was barred
from seeing them until they ran into
them
now that is a heck of a way to bump into
your co-star but obviously effective
ariaster made waves with his debut
feature film hereditary in 2018 a
divisive study of a family in mourning
that set the tone for the style of a24
Horror starring Tony Collette Gabrielle
Byrne and Alex Wolff hereditary was only
the third film in the genre put out by
the new studio it starts out as the
story about the Graham family and their
struggles with grief but you realize
it's just a precursor to the real horror
show a cult worshiping a deity named
payman gotta be honest the first time I
saw the film I thought they were talking
about worshiping something that sounds
delicious with a tall glass of milkman
[Music]
hello
mom mom
after the sixth sense in Fright Night
Tony Collette actually told her agent
she didn't want to do any more dark and
heavy films focusing instead on comedies
now after reading Aster's script she
changed her mind either that or she had
a totally different read on this movie
than I did
between hereditary and his follow-up
film mid-summer Astor made a name for
himself with his confrontational and
traumatic films but compared to the
directors of some of the movies on this
list I mean Astor looks positively well
positive I mean consider that when Alex
Wolf who played the grandson wanted to
go method in a school room possession
scene Astor refused to let the teenager
break his own nose on his desk now it
doesn't sound like much but there are a
ton of directors out there who would
kill for that level of commitment and
it's a credit to ask her that hereditary
only traumatized its audience the cast
and the crew had no problems with
production
foreign
[Music]
John Carpenter's a thing arrived in
theaters as the story told three times
over first as a novella called who goes
there then the thing from another world
in the 1950s but the 1982 version
starring Kurt Russell Wilford Brimley
and Keith David brought something
totally original to the table the
Monstrous creations of 22 year old Rob
bottine
foreign
budget Carpenter allocated 1.5 million
dollars for practical effects needed to
create the thing a parasitic alien
capable of taking any form it was
created with a mixture of chemicals
rubber food products and mechanical
Parts but is it just me or does it sound
like the thing would have just smelled
terrible none of the casts were too fond
of the props either the only actor able
to stomach the experience was Wilford
Brimley a cowboy who wasn't squeamish
when it came to handling Gore now when
asked by Carpenter how he held it
together Brimley said it was like
picking up his laundry on its release he
felt differently though and came down
hard on the special effects Department
of the film saying that the realistic
body horror of the mutated creatures
form was going to negatively affect
audiences
um yeah that's kind of the point
foreign
despite being considered one of the
great cult classics in modern horror
though the movie originally came out to
terrible reviews can you believe it film
magazine sent a fantastic put it in
contention for worst movie of all time
it was only in home video release did
the movie gain the legendary reputation
it has today but at least it's not alone
I mean the thing shares the distinction
of opening and bombing the same weekend
as another now classic Ridley Scott's
Blade Runner and the negative press may
have been caused by yet a third sci-fi
alien movie that had hit theaters just a
few weeks earlier one with a much more
optimistic world view a little movie
called E.T the Extraterrestrial
is anybody home
hello
Toby Hooper's Cinema verite classic The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre shocked
audiences when it debuted in 1974. with
its generous definition of a True Crime
Story the movie ushered in the age of
the slasher but Hooper never intended
for a group of teenagers running with
the face-wearing psycho Leatherface and
his clan of deep fried cannibals to get
such an intense reaction from audiences
across the country in fact it was quite
the opposite he was intending it to be
one of the least bloodiest horror films
of all time and here's what happened the
hoping to get a PG rating that would
have meant more butts and seeds Hooper
decided that the majority of the movie's
violence would only be implied happening
off-screen the plan backfired
tremendously as it turns out that
audience's imaginations were far more
gorrier and expansive than anything he
could have put to Celluloid people ended
up walking out halfway through early
test screenings disgusted by whatever
their minds had come up with to fill in
the blanks of the scene
laughs
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
another reason the movie's biggest
scares happened off screen the budget or
lack thereof The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
was produced by Hooper for a hundred and
forty thousand dollars now with a budget
that small some scenes were Tad more
realistic than they probably should have
been notably the family dinner at the
end which began shooting in broad
daylight and lasted 27 hours with the
cast sweltering in the Texas Heat
the blackout curtains necessary for
shooting a night scene in broad daylight
along with the lack of air conditioning
on location meant in a 110 degree Hot
Box in which the food in the scene
including large chunks of meat ripened
and spoiled I mean we won't get into
details but the cast and crew can recall
frequent barf brakes and instances of
Sanity slippage where the line between
the character and actor would honestly
start to blur
[Music]
thank you
yeah
not unlike the Sawyers who use their
victims corpses for all sorts of
unsavory home crafting projects the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre's lean mean
production may have been gross and
unethical but it was also highly
effective on release it grossed over 30
million dollars which translates to
roughly 113 million dollars today making
it the highest grossing independent film
ever made until that point it only had
four years at the top before John
Carpenter's Halloween came along and
shivied it in the back but more on that
in a bit
alien
[Applause]
in space no one can hear you scream was
actually the tagline for 1979's alien
which is as terrifying as it is an
incorrect assessment of the events of
the film so in Ridley Scottsville you
absolutely hear people screaming as they
were ripped apart sometimes From the
Inside by the entities known as
facehuggers Xenomorphs or more plainly
aliens
now writer Dan O'Bannon originally meant
for the movie's lead to be a male but
the director saw the potential for
arguably the most successful gender swap
character in movie history audiences
connected hard to officer Ellen Ripley
played by Sigourney Weaver a crew member
on the Nostromo who has to fight her way
through both robots and aliens to
survive and save the cat to boot
[Music]
considering the head xenomorph is a
queen you get one of the greatest
accidentally feminist horror movies in
history but try pitching into Studios
back in 1979 they all unanimously
rejected the broad story based on just
its descriptions of graphic violence and
Gore it hadn't even been written yet but
they were able to find funding when Fox
came back around and greenlit alien with
a 4.5 million dollar Budget on one
condition tone it down and tighten it up
board and awaiting funding to begin
production Scott ended up storyboarding
the entire movie he gave it to Fox which
turned around and doubled the budget
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
Dallas
[Applause]
still a storyboard is just a storyboard
and a studio bulked over a few of
Scott's more out there demands like
hiring H.R Geiger to work on the film's
special effects now Geiger already had a
huge influence on the film as Scott had
based the Xenomorphs on the
biomechanical images found in the Swiss
artist book the Necronomicon Fox
eventually relented but not without some
conditions Geiger's explicit depictions
of the alien genitals for example didn't
make the cut Geiger did end up winning
an Academy Award though for his work on
the film in 1980.
in 2007 wame balaguero and Paco Plaza
co-directed the Spanish found footage
film wreck now like a horror version of
The Raid with less martial arts Rex POV
was that of a news crew filming a group
of firefighters for a human interest
story when they respond to a distress
call from one of the Barcelona's
dilapidated Apartments they end up
trapped inside along with the
supernatural infection ripping through
the complex
foreign
[Applause]
the fact that wreck wasn't a traditional
zombie film made it a refreshing Twist
on two already oversaturated genres I
mean for a movie about the undead Rec
was shot as realistically as possible a
trend that we tend to see when
filmmakers have no budget and need to
get creative it was filmed
chronologically with a cast of Mostly
unknowns on location at the city matexa
building in Barcelona because they
couldn't afford sets
love you
awesome
again
dialogue was improvised and the final
scene of the movie was shot in total
darkness but with the camera's infrared
light
now the actors were never given full
scripts so nobody knew what would happen
to them leading to everyone being on
pins and needles every day on the shoot
terrible for morale great for Ambiance
wreck was a breakout hit at the box
office making 32 million dollars
internationally off a two million dollar
budget leading to three sequels and an
American remake quarantine
foreign
this wouldn't be an essential horror
movie list if we failed to include John
Carpenter's 1978 classic Halloween
starring Jamie Lee Curtis making her big
screen debut the battle between High
School babysitter Lori Strode and mute
knife-wielding psychopath Michael Myers
is a Tale As Old As Time Carpenter and
co-writer Deborah Hill wrote Halloween
like a radio play with jump scares every
10 minutes now to make that kind of
clockwork Ambience effective they needed
a good background track which Carpenter
wrote himself the score for Halloween is
written in a rare 5-4 time signature
which the director learned from his
father Carpenter's music skills also
landed him Donald Pleasence who agreed
to be in the film after his daughter was
such a fan of Carpenter's score on
Assault on Precinct 13.
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
because the scenes were shot out of
order Carpenter had to come up with some
clever ways to let his new star know how
she was supposed to react during any
given scene they ended up creating
something called a fear meter which
Jamie Lee Curtis would glance at during
a scene and immediately know how freaked
out to be and here I am making it up as
I go like a sucker
[Music]
do as I said I said trying to find the
perfect mask for Michael Myers to wear
was no easy feat Carpenter was torn
between two different masks a smiling
clown mask with red hair like the one
that he's wearing in the opening when he
kills his sister and a 1975 James Kirk
Star Trek mask with the eyebrows and
sideburns ripped off someone had painted
the face white and used brown spray
paint on the hair when tested out on the
crew the second one out for spookiest
thing to see a grown man wearing around
town and considering that the first one
was a full-on clown mask I mean that's
pretty impressive one viewer who was not
a fan though William Shatner sorry if it
sounds like I'm repeating myself but
this movie was made for less than the
price of a table at the Met Gala on a
300 000 budget Halloween grossed 47
million dollars at the box office I mean
that would be over 177 million dollars
today making Halloween one of the most
successful Independent films of all time
and making wreck look like a bloated
studio production in comparison
foreign
[Music]
I'm home
1980 brought Stanley kubricks to shining
a cinematic piece of art that was all
work and no play to make based on the
Stephen King novel and starring Jack
Nicholson Shelley Duvall and Danny Lloyd
the story follows writer Jack Torrance
who brings his wife and son Danny to the
empty Overlook Hotel after taking a job
as the winter groundskeeper which is
terrifying enough even without the part
where the place is haunted the kid is
psychic and Jack's novel as well I mean
it's kind of repetitive Kubrick was
Infamous for being a meticulous and
demanding director requiring a truly
mind-numbing number of hours committed
for shooting even the simplest scene a
simple scene of Jack bouncing a ball
against the walls of the lobby required
40 takes but none of those touched the
scene on the staircase where Wendy tries
to ward off her crazy husband with a bat
stop swinging the bat
put the bat down now that one actually
made it into the Guinness Book of World
Records for most amount of takes for a
single scene with dialogue 127. now it's
been debated whether or not this number
is accurate and Kubrick actually claimed
that they weren't real takes but more
glorified rehearsals
unsurprisingly though it took five years
for Kubrick to finish the shining and
for the actors it probably felt like a
lot longer and after all that you'd
probably be surprised to learn that the
director only needed three takes to nail
the scene of the elevator bank opening
up to tidal waves of blood but before we
get too excited that's because it took
nine days to set up the massive
practical effect and Kubrick would cut
mid-seeing claiming that it didn't look
realistic enough
foreign
in the end it took over a year for one
of the bloodiest scenes in movie history
to make it to Celluloid during which
time the gutters of the nearby Village
of boar hamwood ran red funny enough
Kubrick was able to escape past the MPAA
even though they had a strict no blood
and movie trailer rule by telling them
that the shot was just rust colored
water
a maniac a raving thing
she just goes
a little mad sometimes
we all go a little mad sometimes
the daddy of all horror thriller's
psycho arrived in 1960 to change how
audiences felt about showers motels and
Mama's Boys forever
Alfred Hitchcock directed Janet Lee and
Anthony Perkins in career defining
performances as Mary and crane a young
woman on the run after taking off with
her boss's doe and Norman Bates the
handsome stranger who runs the motel
that she's unlucky enough to stop at no
spoilers but Norman's got some severe
mommy issues
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
compared to the bloodbath in The Shining
psycho's shower scene one of the
greatest of all time moments in movie
history was actually finished along with
the rest of the film in under three
months psycho is actually more like some
other films on the list made on a micro
budget after Paramount refused to
bankroll the movie and Hitchcock had to
put up the dough himself to get it made
with only eight hundred thousand dollars
of his own cash and the crew from his TV
show Alfred Hitchcock Presents the
director was forced to cut corners and
colored film stock was the first thing
to go this led to what Bob Ross might
call some happy accidents like being
able to substitute chocolate syrup for
blood in the shower scene
[Music]
still the shower was the most difficult
psycho scene to shoot especially after
they were forced to go back and do
reshoots when Hitchcock's Eagle Eye wife
noticed that Lee's pupil kept dilating
in the extreme close-up after she was
supposed to be dead now Hitchcock was no
Kubrick and was not a fan of having to
redo shots considering it's now widely
one of the most successful suspense
films of all time we'd like to think it
was worth it
what
what are you talking about
I feel it I feel it breathing on me
please
Jason Blum joined the ranks of hallowed
horror producers like Bob Shea and Dino
dilaurantis when he financed A Haunted
House micro Indy called Paranormal
Activity it was shot four get ready for
this fifteen thousand dollars grossing
over a hundred and ninety million
dollars which for those of you guys
keeping score at home makes it the most
successful independent horror film of
all time by a wide shot we should be
telling kids hey you can either attend
one semester of film school or make the
next Paranormal Activity
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I mean the production was kept as
minimal as possible with the director
Oren pelly using his own home as the set
Micah slow pulled double duty as both
the film star and it's cameraman and
both leads took home a whopping 500
check to be in the film and most of the
dialogue improvised Paranormal Activity
success was in part due to blum's genius
at marketing he would tape audiences
during screenings waiting for jump
scares to send them screening and
promoted the film solely based on their
reactions
foreign
[Music]
castle-esque move worked and Paranormal
Activity was beyond successful giving
birth to blumhouse Productions Blum
stated that he sought the rights to the
film after making the mistake of passing
on the Blair Witch Project a decade
earlier but by far the best fact about
the first Paranormal Activity was that
Steven Spielberg received a screener of
the film after Paramount and DreamWorks
purchased the distribution rights after
watching the movie at home his bedroom
door mysteriously locked itself trapping
the E.T director inside his home and
forcing him to call a locksmith to pry
it open Spielberg actually returned the
screener to DreamWorks in a garbage bag
ah
Chris doctors
and for our final entry we are going
back to 1971 when director William
friedkin decided to adapt William
blattay's hit novel The Exorcist about a
lapsed priest and a demon named Pazuzu
supposedly inspired by true events The
Exorcist tells the story of Father
Damien Karas who was called by a famous
actress to save her daughter Reagan from
satanic possession friedkin was actually
given access to the Diaries kept by the
priests involved with the real-life
exorcism the novel is based on
I'm speaking to the person inside of
Reagan now
if you were there you two are hypnotized
I must answer all my questions
come forward
and answer me now casting Reagan
actually proved to be difficult due to
the film's adult language and themes
Linda Blair beat out over 500 other
young actresses for the role including a
13 year old Jamie Lee Curtis whose
mother rejected the role on her behalf
was it because of where Reagan tells the
old priest played by Max moncito exactly
where he should shove his crucifix I'm
gonna go ahead and say Yes Blair
actually showed up for an audition
without an appointment and went over
friedkin with her comprehension of the
subject material now if Kubrick was a
grueling director to work for friedkin
was a whole other level often catching
actors off guard to film their honest
reactions this led to behind the scenes
stories that ranged from shayden Freud
to e to legit dangerous friedkin would
do everything to get the shot frequently
misleading actors about what was about
to happen he fired Blanks on set slapped
an actual priest in the face and told
actor Jason Miller that Reagan's pea
soup vomit would hit his chest not
directly into his face and mouth shut up
[Applause]
in the name of the father and of the son
that the Holy Spirit
by this sign of the Holy Cross of our
Lord Jesus Christ after all that effort
how did audiences react to blood and
sweat put into the exorcists they got
sick literally the film had a visceral
effect on viewers that many vomited or
fainted during screenings reception
booths in theaters resorted to handing
out barf bags and despite all this the
exorcists must have been doing something
right because it became the first horror
film ever nominated for Best Picture
well friends that about wraps things up
for today's episode of RT Essentials
thankfully now I'm not sure if my nerves
could take much more talk of the spooky
content but what am I saying feed all
that scary stuff directly into my eyes
forever I'm ready for it I'm nazarez and
thanks for watching RT Essentials I'll
see you guys next time that is if I'm
not too busy watching malignant for the
eighth time but stay tuned and keep it
creepy
[Applause]
[Music]